you're watching here's what we've got
for you on this week's show a FIFA
superstar at the top of his game a retro
looking phone that does more than you
think and things get dark in our games
review welcome to swipe now if you're
into gaming you'll know all about the
rise of eSports game is competing in
televised tournaments posted from
studios like this one in leicester for
big cash prizes it's thought by the end
of this year the global eSports market
will be worth around 350 million pounds
but will it never be as popular as other
traditional sports here's Chris it was a
clash between two giants of the German
game played on a virtual pitch after get
the lead up to four lose it's
embarrassing for me for me it would end
in defeat but there was no shame in
losing to someone who plays this video
game for a living dave is the official
FIFA player for German football side
Wolfsburg he represents the club at
gaming tournaments and events in the
scene you play a game that's so
relatable to every football club around
the world it's just surprised I know
it's taken this long for it to happen I
think I was chosen cool and of course
you know I've got some good history
behind me I'm still a good player while
FIFA gaming stars aren't earning the
same sort of caches were now though or
Messi there's still chance to earn big
at the highest level of competitive
gaming the halo World Championship held
in California last month saw the biggest
ever prize pool for an eSports
tournament the winning team took home a
million dollars the money in competitive
gaming might still be catching up to
many traditional sports but there are
other areas where the similarities
already exist
the agency side is very similar to the
football scene in the United Kingdom if
you look at someone who's playing in
Division four they probably don't have
representation beyond perhaps a very
curious and caring mother now if you
talk to somebody who's playing perhaps
in the Premier they're going to have
that the same is true the best players
are going to have representation in the
UK it's hard to imagine eSports ever
matching the Premier League in terms of
popularity but this new studio in
Leicester hopes to boost the country's
competitive gaming infrastructure
eSports in the UK lags behind the global
phenomenon is really the talent in terms
of the actual gaming teams we have had
some really good teams emerge from the
UK scene but generally speaking it's
down to the fact that they've not had
the the practice the platform to
practice esports is a rapidly growing
global industry worth hundreds of
millions of dollars and in countries
where it's most popular like South Korea
players are already household names so
one day people like Dave could become
the next breed of sporting celebrity
Chris Craig and Sky News stay with us
still to come I get a look at a phone
said to be bridging the gap between
generations but first here's a roundup
of some of this week's other tech news
who knew there was a techie way to drink
wine well this bottling and dispensing
system called cuvee apparently stops
oxygen from reaching your drink while a
screen tells you how many glasses are
left it doesn't work on any old bottle
though only their own the project
launched on IndieGoGo for US customers
also on the crowdfunding site a pet
activity tracker that works out how much
food and exercise your cat or dog needs
to stay healthy
the French team behind canny fit say it
can also help you find your animal if it
gets lost we've seen toys that help you
learn to code before but this robots on
Wheels lets you shoot lasers play music
and change voices to Kodi box creators
say learning has to be fun the project's
crowdfunding on Kickstarter and a new
apps launch for people with food
allergies all those on a special diet
whether you're paleo or
arian spoon guru endorsed by the charity
allergy UK can scan barcodes letting you
check if products are safe and lists
recipes coming up in our games review
time is on your side
now we're gonna break away from here if
it's just a moment and take it to London
this week I met the inventor of free
folk it's a service for those who find
smart technology a little bit
comfortable you think we like to meet
people here on skype with big ideas and
then we like to get industry experts
find out what they think pass through
phones as a service that uses
easy-to-use mobile phones so it's got a
big keypad clear screen and good sound
it looks just like an old phone to me
well it is a lot like an old phone but
phones used to be really easy to use and
they've got difficult and complicated
what makes one very special the
important thing is that we use the
button on the back the customer presses
the button the call then goes through to
our call center in South End call goes
through we're making the corner yes I'm
pinnacle so on my screen I can see what
they can see on the screen in South a
very well and you can I speak to Gemma
Morris please so if we look at what and
you can see on her screen we can see
your name Jim Morris she's gonna connect
you to me now oh here you are now if my
granny we got her one of these and she
didn't really use it but she just liked
having it will she be penalized if she
didn't use it within a certain time
period like would you terminate her
contract if she didn't use it in four
months no we'd never do that we would
never terminate a person's contract
without speaking to them first
now as you know Simon hear us right we
like to get an industry experts view on
new products and services and this week
we've got the view of Jonathon tape from
PricewaterhouseCoopers
this is what he's have to say about the
story phones I really like this idea it
uses existing safe technology and we're
seeing an increasing demand for a mix of
human interaction with technology
offerings there are though some
important issues that I think need to be
managed developing the right marketing
channels is critical particularly in the
health and care sectors the landscape is
littered with great ideas that just
never got in front of the right people
the technology may be safe today but
something new is inevitably going to
come on down the track so what do you
make of that
how are you going to stay ahead of the
competition in terms of competition and
we've got whole plans for innovations
one of the things we're looking at is
putting a hearing aid in the network so
very unusually we actually handle the
calls for all our customers through our
own computers and we can give each
customer a personalized sound profile to
cope with their hearing this is where
the shoutcasters six that basically
means that well he isn't a commentator
he is our games reviewer this week is
Adam Savage with his pick of new
releases
welcome to drangleic home to the stars
of a thousand children's nightmares Dark
Souls 3 is actually the fourth iteration
in a series which began back in 2009
with Demon Souls and it's gone from
strength to strength
ever since created by hit attacker
Miyazaki developer of the hugely popular
2015 blood-borne the story revolves
around the unconditioned restoring the
guardians of the flame to their rightful
Thrones we all know the Dark Souls games
are about the combat and this time
around the movements are lot more fluid
and the overall designs a lot more vivid
and it could be the most enchanting to
date I think the Dark Soul series gave
birth to the term ragequit as its
relentless difficulty can be incredibly
challenging but if you're someone who
enjoys that make sure to bubble wrap the
television and mostly immerse furniture
quantum break may sound like an 80s TV
show about time-traveling surfers be an
actual fact that games about
time-traveling students come to think of
it that's pretty much exactly the same
thing if you're a gamer who enjoys the
odds superpower and games which rely on
your choices that determine the story's
outcome then this game is definitely for
you time isn't just something you'll be
moving forward and back through any more
as quantum break has actually managed to
weaponize it you can use it as a shield
to level buildings reverse bullets and
give Doc Brown a serious headache full
of towing and throwing you'll be doing
through the space-time continuum with a
stellar cast quantum break does in fact
intersperse a digital TV show as well
when you complete certain segments
you'll get to witness this and find out
a bit more about the bad guys whilst
you've been going about your business it
sounds like a smart idea we'll find out
whether or not time really is power when
it hits shelves soon the latest
experience from Team codemasters
features 17 gloriously designed cars
across 36 stages and you can bet your
bottom dollar that with all the
available DLC coming our way very soon
there'll be a trunkload of exciting new
add-ons the gameplay feels really
intuitive and it looks great as you race
around mountain sides and forests but
for me it's all about the drifting you
can almost feel the track dust getting
caught up in your nostril hairs
dirt rally is a frontrunner when it
comes to racing simulations and if
you're a petrol head this is just about
as close you're going to get to the real
thing now I don't know whose bones they
are but I feel like probably time we got
out of the way here take a look at Sky
News on the mobile iPad catch-up and sky
cue to stay up-to-date with all the
latest tech stories throughout the week
I'll see you again next time bye bye